dena me asks why are you uploading the
episodes to facebook instead of
attaching a photo linking to your
website of the video or using YouTube
the reason i'm posting this video in
facebook natively is because I fancy
myself as an expert or someone who at
least wants to be one day an expert and
really understanding things like you
know what the book was written about can
you get it back there d Rock Jab Jab Jab
right hook a lot of you read it you know
that I care about being native being
platform-specific I am seeing data that
shows me that if I put the video in
natively and upload it versus linking it
to youtube or my website about twenty to
thirty thousand more people see the
video I care about them seeing the video
I don't need to feel good about where my
traffic comes from I don't need the
vanity of having more YouTube views I
don't need to see my website getting
more traffic because I'm going to sell
ads on it I want people to hear the
answers to the questions I'm playing the
long game I want to bring value and the
more people that see it the more value
on providing if the feed natively is
going to allow me to reach more people
then that's what I'm gonna do